hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well earlier on in the
Mona loggia in the chapters that I've
got outlined here namely 911 and 31 in
particular in some instead of this
notion of the word as being the creative
expression by which creation all the
creative things that are not God that
not the divine substance are brought
into being out of non-being and as we've
seen they're not entirely in non-being
before they come to exist or even after
they cease existing in our world of
experience because as the anthem says
they exist in the word and the word is
you might say the knowledge or the
expression like we have here the wisdom
the reason on the divine substance not
as something separate from it but as
what that what that is you might think
of it as in its activity in its using of
those things and the word itself is
going to be as we'll see in some other
videos it's its own entity although not
a distinct substance from the Creator so
the Creator creates through the word
which is distinct and yet
I'm the same thing as the the creative
the divine substance that's a little bit
more complex we'll get into that in a
moment here what we're interested in is
the relationship between the creative
things and this this creative word in
which the things already pre exist and
will you might say too quaint another
phrase post exist after they no longer
are here within the the realm of our
experience and this raises some puzzles
for an so we've already seen some of
them in those previous chapters now
we're going to look at chapters 34
through 36 where he approaches this
again because there are still some some
puzzles left so he's asking in chapter
34 how he says how can such different
things namely the creating and created
essence now what does he mean by that
the creating essence is got the the
divine but also the created essence
meaning the whole nature of created
being so we can talk about created
essences or beatings a sexy I and we can
also talk about essence as being the
totality of created being how can they
both he asked be uttered or expressed by
the same word given that they seem to be
so radically different from each other
especially since the word is co eternal
with him otters it whereas creation is
not they says well one way to understand
this is that the word is in fact supreme
wisdom and supreme reason in which all
creative things actually are so it's not
as if they they do in fact is created
things have a time-bound space-bound
existence right but that's only one
dimension of their existence they also
sister he have being in the supreme
wisdom and and reason so he goes in and
he says any work that is made according
to a craft always not only when it is
made but even before it is made and
after it is destroyed exists in that
craft as nothing other than the craft
itself so we see this this notion of
sort of like a divine blueprint or
pattern that handsome was using back in
these earlier chapters being brought to
the fore again to explain well how how
it is that the word can be expressing
the word or God or you know sort of
self-expression and also expressing
created things which are finite then and
limited so it exists in in this you know
in the mind of God we could say as the
thing exists in the craft now this is an
imperfect analogy because you know when
we think about the artist who creates is
something different than the craft by
which they create not the same thing for
the divine substance which creates by
its very self through its supreme wisdom
and reason so he says when that Supreme
Spirit utters himself he also unders all
created things for before they were made
and once they've already been made and
when they are destroyed anyway changed
they always exist in him this is a very
important point now guess what they are
in themselves in say in their own
existence right so you can say that be
the you know what things are in
themselves is not quite the same thing
as the in themself are in itself of the
divine we tend to think that when we're
dealing with what is in itself we are
grasping the bottom foundation level of
reality Anselm is actually saying here
no that's not in fact the case the way
things are for us in themselves is not
actually what they are in their most
true be it so
he says creative things exist in the
word not just as what they are but as
what the word is that's an interesting
thing to say he says what he himself is
for in themselves they are changeable
beings changeable essences creating
according created according to an
unchangeable reason right the divine
reason they're created after some sort
of pattern but they don't can fully
conform to the patterns for their mouth
the other their mutable they change they
come into being they go out of being
sometimes they're not entirely what they
want to be he says in the in the Divine
Being they are that first essence and
first truth of existing and the more so
are in any way the more they are in any
way like him the more truly and
excellently they exist so what this
implies is that if you consider myself
for it for example Anselm would say that
I exist before my earthly existence you
know our art are we could call it
objective reality the in itself however
we want to put it I exist in God's mind
there's a me a dr. Sandler a Gregory
Sadler who at one time was a nameless
babies right who is more real than the
one that you're actually you know seeing
right here what is the one that you're
seeing right here is actually just an
image of the real dr. salgo right here
who I know reflexively you know you meet
me somewhere you run into the doctor Sam
right we're at a class together on the
train or something like that the
implication of this is that for every
one of us there is another us who exists
in the Divine Word in the supreme wisdom
and reason who is more like the Divine
Word than we are and insofar as we
approach to that we take on more being
and reality it's not just us
rational beings it's everything all the
way down to the very lowest scale of
being so if you're confused about that
take a look at the video specifically on
degrees of being because that's going to
be important here this is why chapter 35
is important Ansem is going to assert
that all things are life and truth in
the word what does that mean that means
that things that are not themselves
living are in fact life the life of the
Divine in the word so that for example
this chalk in itself and also the
representation of it that you have that
you're watching right now is not
something living in the word as you
might say part of the word little part
is not a good term here this is
something alive the try that it
corresponds to we can also talk about
these things being knowledge because the
word knows intimately more intimately
than is possible for us precisely what
it is that it is expressing all these
created beings that are created in part
through its expression so that's a very
important point and this leads us to
another sort of thing to think about as
wide as a set of meditations in chapter
36 how does God or how does the word how
does how does all of this stuff take
place the knowledge what is that
knowledge like and handsome says look
that knowledge is actually strictly
speaking incomprehensible he says from
this it can be most clearly comprehended
that no human knowledge can comprehend
how that spirit utters or knows the
things that were made so we're able to
comprehend something that provides a
limit or if you use it's actually better
said not to be a limit as such but more
like an abyss something that's
bottomless that we cannot possibly fan
we're able to comprehend what it is that
we're not able to conquer
and I know that sounds a little bit
tricky but that's that's what I ants on
the saying here he says no one doubts
that created substances exist in
themselves quite differently from how
they exist in our knowledge so we're
actually beginning with our own
knowledge here in talking about about
this difference I'm not the same thing
as what you are watching or hearing on
this this video right there's all sorts
of aspects of me that are being left out
you can't see anything other than what's
on the screen here go on and on it out
of that right my dentist changed
coloring boost the sound all those sorts
of things that's that's the equivalent
of our knowledge here the things in
themselves are different than our
knowledge so he says nobody doubts that
right after all in themselves they exist
through their own essence anselm is not
denying the reality of a creative things
here by the way they exist through their
own essence where is in our knowledge
about their essences but their
likenesses that exist they says so it
follows they exist more truly in
themselves that in our knowledge to the
extent that they exist more truly
somewhere through their essence then
through their likeness if that's the
case he says then it's also clear every
creative substance exists more truly in
the word than they do in themselves so
he's making a movement away from the
things as they are in what we call
objective or empirical reality and the
staining that yes that's all real but he
had more real more true more living even
is how these things are in the word he
says in the understanding of the creator
so if our knowledge is as much surpassed
by created substances as their life is
fall short of their essence how he asks
how will the human mind understand what
that essence and that knowledge our life
since they're higher yet then created
substances so what we have here is we
can say
things meaningfully about the divine but
we're running into you like I said
limits or abyssus or you might even say
paradoxes all of this is quite tricky
because we're dealing with something
that surpasses what we're normally used
to thinking in terms of